c'est un voyage au centre de la terre
une plongée dans un monde où la roche se
fait cristal
et où les yeux se mettent à sautiller
comme les pieds
c'est impossible de l'expliquer avec des
mails faut vraiment le voir c'est comme
entrer dans une autre dimension
tout simplement fait c'est un palais
matin même difficile de croire qu'une
chose aussi spectaculaire soit juste
latin plein milieu d'une bataille
cette montagne du sud-est de
l'andalousie il faut d'abord arpenté ses
reliefs avant de pénétrer dans ses
entrailles
nous sommes aux petits de la montagne de
l'aigle qui se tenir sur la commune des
poulpes et c'est une fierté pour nous
parce que l'endroit est vraiment
spectaculaire
riche en minerais le site est exploité
dès l'époque romaine au 19e siècle il
devient même l'une des principales du
pays
sont d'anciens frères qui permettait de
foudre bien une règle pour les
transporter plus facilement à l'époque
les mineurs chez dante est déjà arrivé
d'avoir des cristaux anciens mais il
était tellement obsédé par le faire de
l'argent qu'ils n'ont jamais vraiment
prêté attention
pour nous enfoncer dans ces tunnels nous
suivons milagros carretera monde et les
géologues et c'est l'une des seules à
connaître parfaitement ce labyrinthe
souterrain où les mineurs risquer leur
vie
l'afld avait une échelle de secours ont
utilisé pour entrer ou sortir en cas
d'urgence d'aidé la mine
c'est santa barbara la patronne des
mineurs il la vénérée et demander sa
protection
parti comme disait la mine on sait
combien la rente mais jamais si on va en
ressortir
plus de quatre kilomètres de galeries
exploitée jusqu'aux années 60 et où les
plus belles surprises se cache parfois
[Musique]
dans l'obscurité des abymes
ces minéraux sont floraison il le sauna
est que lorsqu'on les éclairs à la
lumière ultraviolette
c'est magique 7 min en voûte située
entre qui on tombe amoureux été nommé
une poussière des toiles comme suspendu
dans le vide et le silence après le
fracas de pioches et de la dynamique qui
a régné ici pendant des siècles
voici ce que l'on appelle la cathédrale
une salle gigantesque qui a été
entièrement vidées par l'homme et en
creusant toujours plus loin à 60 mètres
de profondeur des géologues ont fait par
hasard en 1999 une découverte inattendue
une grotte entièrement tapissé de
cristaux la plus grande j'ai haute
d'europe
et alhassane alkaly mans est enfermé
dans une zone volcanique
alors cette qualité de la forme d'un
ballon rugby de 8 m de livres s'est
remplie autrefois d'un liquide très
riche en minéraux à attendre et à la
vieillesse en cristallisant ils ont leur
message ils ont créé ta si transparent
où la reine venir à me ramène folio
jarrett 1 reste à l'est et les rayons
le spectacle war ne s'offrent qu'à une
personne à la fois alors aucun risque de
voir la géode de pulpe y succomber au
tourisme de masse elle restera un
trésors rares et précieux enfoui à
jamais sous la montagne